hi in this video tutorial I would teach
you how to perform descriptive
statistics in our sample in graphpad
prism 7 so let's click on the graph but
his prism 7 and we would take our old
example and we would go to our raw data
set so now we want to for particular
group a and Group B we want to calculate
all the descriptive statistics like mean
median mode the standard deviation
standard error and all others now
question comes how to do that in order
to do that we would go to analyze and
then click on analyze then we would
click on the column statistics in column
statistics we would select the column
statistics and click on OK after that we
we are a new window there are options
for descriptive statistics like minimum
and a maximum mean median standard error
of mean we can also judge the skewness
and kurtosis of the distribution we can
judge the percentile score let's say we
want to know the 75th percentile you can
calculate the coefficient of variation
geometric mean all these things and when
we hit ok and we would take two
significant digits for our adults and
when we when we would hit OK
the result would show everything so in
this particular result you can see
between male and female all the scores
like to a fifth percentile median then
you 775 percentile maximum scores means
that a deviation error of mean
everything is written so this is how we
can calculate all the necessary
descriptive statistics using graphpad
prism I hope this video helped you
please like and subscribe thank you